tout juste nommé est déjà au chevet des
dijonnais jean castex accompagnée de son
nouveau ministre de l'intérieur avait
une mission double pour ce premier
déplacement en région montrer son
soutien aux forces de l'ordre mais aussi
aux habitants du quartier des grésillés
traumatisé par les violences du mois de
juin
première étape ce matin le commissariat
pour un discours de soutien
inconditionnel aux forces de l'ordre
je me suis dit il faut aller voir total
est sur place j'ai voulu venir ici à
dijon dire aux forces de sécurité tout
le soutien du gouvernement dans la lutte
déterminée qu'elles doivent conduire
face à ce type d'événements
hélas à dijon où ailleurs trop fréquents
deuxième étape la plus lourde de sens le
quartier des grésillés poignée de main
hésitante gestes barrières oblige les
deux membres du nouveau gouvernement
retrouve le maire françois rebsamen
visite volontairement en contact des
habitants et au bout de quelques pas
seulement un premier échange face aux
caméras curité au quartier si vous
voulez que votre discours soit audible
il faut aussi la vérité vraie et la
vérité vraie c'est que pendant 72 heures
les gens ici ont été complètement
abandonnée moi je suis aussi venu ici à
tous
à porter avec le ministre un message
d'apaisement
respectons nous les uns les autres c'est
le fondement de la société républicains
rencontrent plus organiser enfin avec
les associations du quartier des
grésillés avec toujours la même volonté
très affichée ramener l'ordre
républicain partout sur le territoire